all right next one all right the most
degenerate moments wow degeneracy is a
normal thing on the trash taste podcast
it runs through the blood it does it
does uh and I think this has been an
award every year so far because there
has never been a year when there's not
been some degenerate [__] [__]
happened
see because I I don't even think I
looked at the the nominations
all this is like we said that yeah all
right let's find out let's go through
nominations the boy review uh Sleepless
A Midsummer Night stream
I want to wipe that from my memory man
no fun with the with the pp with the
tapioca
if you if you know you know if you don't
know congratulations yeah that whole
episode like that episode just gave me
my curse man that was that was so curse
that's that's when that's what we went
too far I think and then we also got our
boy shindoel making a planet ape
sturgeon which uh I'm disappointed
because I haven't seen it yet I really
want to read it everything that man does
is like okay but why like just because
you could doesn't mean you should it's
like no one needed the Planet of the
Apes don't you I couldn't get over that
in the episode I was like what what
someone asked for it no one asked though
that's the thing it's like he was like
anybody want it no no I'm gonna make it
yeah it's surprising that in the entire
episode we had to pick one moment
because I kind of just want to put that
in just shindoell himself as like the
most degenerate moment absolutely of
trash taste because that's what my vote
would go to uh and then there's the boys
watch read over here or I guess it's me
explaining read over here yeah we we had
two explanation videos here so we had
Joey explains redo of healer to saikuno
and Ghana explains domestic girlfriend
to psychino as well which uh I have
which one's more degenerate I mean
psychino hasn't like dm'd me back ever
since we recorded that episode so he's
just like straight up like you know man
I'm I'm sorry I swear to God domestic
girlfriend just sounds so degenerate
you're like God damn it like I'm a sad
person watching this
I guess it's fun yeah yeah it's it's
good it's good I'm not gonna start again
I don't want to hear it so I've done
that enough I've done it alone uh the
major restoration led to hentai
censorship in Japan oh yeah she's
writing about how uh right now ranting
about Harry was unhappy that the pawn
was censored yeah yeah he was going on
and it was we had an entire history
lesson of Japan uh that started from the
Meiji restoration that led to like Meiji
restoration means pixelated dick and
vagina in Japan only reason why it
happened
nothing good came out her parents to a
girl's pile that's pretty degenerate
that is pretty generous but not as a
generous Ludwig masturbating 18 times in
one day I completely forgot I don't
believe it yeah I don't believe him no
that's fine yeah he's like there's no
way there's no way absolutely no way I I
think the upper human limit I could
believe ten yeah like I could believe
that if you were really going for it and
you took every aphrodisiac and Viagra
but like I just 18 no way hey bro he did
a marathon of marathon of jacking off
yeah he did a marathon of shindoel's
like bibliography that's on average you
like you've done it like one 1.2 hours a
day yeah yeah I think that's crazy how
how much if you're awake right you're
awake on average 16 hours a day he was
nodding on average every 30 minutes yeah
so uh more than one at 100 more than
that one hour it's just under I I take I
take more than now just to recover from
them yeah let alone doing another one
absolutely no one so there's no way yeah
um but only one can take it yeah and I I
genuinely have no idea who's gonna win I
don't there are a lot of DeGeneres
there's a lot of degeneracy yeah uh some
maybe less than others I just I just
don't want the MILF manner to win I
don't want to relive that I I don't want
to relive that yeah that's where
degeneracy has gone too far I'm secretly
hoping that shindo will get the dog I
want shindo I won't be surprised if
Sydney takes this one as well
[Music]
the winner of the most degenerate moment
of the Year Ludwig masturbating 18 times
in one day
that is yeah well I mean on paper that
is just it's just yeah yeah yeah yeah
that it went by a lot yeah I love being
one by 37.
37 of the vote loving one because that
is DJing his [__] no sane person
would do it no congratulations Ludwig
yeah do you remember what you jacked off
to Ludwig I'm just curious because that
must have been some like top tier s-tier
[__] Noel
[Music]
he ended it on the planet planets of the
apes he went like backwards he was like
all right I'm done now he was gonna go
from the 19th he's like yeah
it can't be done all right what's the
next the next category oh there's a new
one this is the U.S state we are least
likely to revisit so the reason why
we're putting this new category in is
because for those of you don't know uh
late last year we did a US tour we went
to a bunch of States some new some old
um and uh we I feel like we've got to
experience like pretty much a good
balance of all of The Vibes of the
states of the US even though we didn't
go to all of them yeah uh and so we
decided to have an award for what the
viewers would think out of just the
stories and for everyone who went to the
tour what is the most likely State we're
like we're not going to revisit that was
that was the sentence I made in my head
yeah
uh because uh we did have part of our
show where we did vote uh we did let the
audience vote on which states did they
lease want to be isekai to yes and we
wanted to see if there was a general
Vibe we got on our tour we wanted to see
if the wider order audience would have
the same Vibe as the people who went on
the tour and actual Americans themselves
as well because there was one clear
winner that uh was voted in our live
shows yeah uh but the categories let's
check out this one were
Florida Ohio Arizona the entire Midwest
but why is the entire Midwest here
so who's gonna win one state or 12. Ohio
is in the midwest
that's like putting out the cigarette
butt on on the orphan you know what I
mean
yeah well um I have my answer I have my
answer as well okay okay so we all have
our answers because we were on the tour
but for the international audience now
for our International audience the US
states that you'll think we're at least
likely to revisit is
once again congratulations Ohio you have
now won the worldwide award for the
least the state that everyone loves to
clown on the most you won the Nationals
and you won the Internationals now jobs
everywhere how much percentage is that
one 21 51
I like the Midwest I just didn't like
Cleveland Ohio yeah I mean I heard
Columbus is great yeah I don't know if
it is according to people in Ohio yeah
this is Cincinnati's good but Cleveland
was a ghost town yeah yeah yeah I mean I
I have to like the Midwest because I'm
bounds there by [__] like blood and
bond and marriage now so I'm like it
sounds like a year problem Wisconsin
that's that's good that's cool cheese
let's just say this wasn't a shocker
yeah I think we're all expecting this uh
because on tour was the exact same thing
I just honestly I put this award uh
category in because I just wanted to uh
give Ohio
yeah yeah
just one last time baby one last time